i want to know what's going to happen
because elon is now has access to the
twitter firehose of all of the data to
analyze because he doesn't believe that
there's less than five percent bots
there's definitely nothing they gave it
to him they gave him the fire hose but
so but so now it's on him to basically
oh wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
what was that
yeah they gave him access
so he's his team is in from what i read
oh yeah wow three days ago yeah three
days ago yo so this is this is actually
big news
the uh the tricky business of elon
getting access to twitter fire getting
twitter fire hose access twitter has
reportedly given the billionaire access
to its full stream of tweets and related
user data is your privacy in jeopardy yo
if elon's if elon was evil he could make
some crazy ai right now with that with
that data well he's using he's using his
ai to come back at them to negotiate the
deal to get twitter for less because
he's gonna you know it's like basically
whose analytics are better
and who can detect spam better and who
has the proof to show it so he's he's
going to use this to for his own
leverage and deal you know the spam bots
on twitter it's probably massive it's
probably massive what would you estimate
i would say
at least
25 can you say for mines are you allowed
to
um it is
at least
we don't it's really hard to tell i will
say i like in i don't want to you know
speak on twitter's behalf but it's hard
to detect because there's humans running
them some of them are half and half it's
at least ten percent elon says
it's more
than five percent yeah i hope those are
the five percent that have called me a
libtard cuck
that would make my name well elon thinks
it's over fifty percent
yeah that's a big number but i don't
think he's wrong that sounds like a big
i'm not saying he's right i'm saying
i think that may be the case twitter is
is political power yeah and so if
if we don't like you you know jamie we
can send 50 bots at you all saying these
similar but different things to make you
feel like some you've done something
wrong you'll change your behavior so
twitter is an excellent place to control
the political conversation if you have
bots that's a great point that's a great
creepy right yeah but again all not all
bots are bad
you know
hashtag not all that's the thing there's
a bunch of bots in it it's like
weatherbot yeah there's like stockbot
yeah and it's just like but you know are
there some other bots that people may
think are not like notorious but they're
actually not bad you came to mind
that yeah nefarious that's it i mean a
bot is just a
auto posting or like programmatic tool
to to post so
there's all kinds like everything within
every genre there could be you know
there's chat bots that are extremely
useful
yeah there's tons of content so so like
to say ban all bots like makes
absolutely no sense related to the bot
conversation elon musk is also planning
to release robots which he says
according to him will be selling more
than tesla cars what kind of robots um
robots that will be helping you with
daily tasks uh this is also the same
elon musk by the way that said that
humans would eventually be able to
download their brains into robots you
know i've played detroit become human
i'm not gonna make that mistake when the
duke comes to me and says he wants to
paint and like be my son and i'll be
like anything you say dude
have you guys played that game no i saw
a little bit about it though yeah it's
basically the they're helper androids
and they become sentient
and then the humans are like no and you
know they try to destroy them and then
they have a revolution guys just
again
how are you doing today jamie you heard
a lot of new information that you never
heard before how are you dealing with
all of this
kind of throw this all out you're the
most worried about being canceled and
i'm like i'm gonna have to fight a robot
this is a lot
this is like humanity's on the brink of
potentially being canceled if we do this
yeah can we they're trying to take away
the second amendment just as this is
happening listen it'd be funny if like
we all make fun of joe biden and then
like after his speech where he says some
random gibberish he walks in the back
stands upright and then like his face
opens and then they like they tweak some
things and he's like thank you for
fixing my face human and then it like
goes back in they're trying to they're
trying to describe
yeah
distract him with nonsense mumbo jumbo
dribble
up the stairs again make it fall up the
stairs again the ai red sun
make your enemy think you are weak oh
yeah
yeah and then we're not gonna we're all
gonna give up our guns and then the
robots are gonna all the all the
democrats and republicans come out and
then just like rip all their skin off
and their terminators they got us and
we're like oh no we gave up our guns
it's so close to having a bunch of like
little mosquito-sized drones that can
fly a thousand miles an hour controlled
by the world economic forum we're so
close to that like why would you even
consider giving up weaponry at this
moment what's it what
i mean you might need if you have like a
magnetron or something you can take out
massive drones flying at you at a
thousand miles an hour like tiny shields
same thing with asteroids or comets
we're not so it's not so good to look
for individual ones and try and blast
them out of the sky because there's too
many you need to make a deflection
shield that's always active right so if
you have a gun and they unleash a
thousand micro drones at a thousand
miles an hour towards you you're gonna
turn into swiss cheese i know what
you're gonna do oh my god what if our
john connor is jake paul and he's trying
to warn us with those tweets okay he's
starting slow yeah
a real slow burst he saw terminator 2 he
knows he can't just come straight out
yeah i'll become a boxer
learning how to fight you know famous
people i mean that'd be great dude the
angle of this wired article is so
ridiculous too it's like elon is talking
about making encrypted messages on
twitter and they're coming actually the
angle of this article is coming after
elon for getting access
even though he's the one sort of
criticizing twitter for the unencrypted
messages it's just like you can you can
detect the bias oh you can detect it
from the super villain picture they use
he literally looks like a bond villain
that's the first thing i thought if
they're saying are you going to be safe
is your dad going to be safe now that
elon hasn't done what about now
blackrock has it right now because
they're invested in that company i don't
know who's on the board
has it like who gets it who at the
company would have access to all the
fire hose i mean well we knew from the
hat remember when everyone's like elon's
dms got hacked but i think bidens did
like yeah and
dude all the twitter mods like that just
read people's messages i mean like
twitter dms are completely open season
for mods
it appears because that
that's what the hacker got access to and
he was just a man and private post too i
don't know if you can post privately on
twitter can you just your follower but
that's all just straight up open
available to all the admins and mods
maybe not all of them i would guess so
but i've never been back there
yeah i like that elon freed the uh his
tesla patents all your all your patents
are belong to us he's like you know if
you can make electric cars better than
me do it because we need more electric
cars yeah but we need elon to actually
open source spacex code tesla code
we're going to be we're going to be uh
testing out bonding uh starling that's
going to be oh yeah nice so we got
we got a couple more than one star link
i don't know what the rules are but you
know we have the business how's the
performance 182 down five up that's
incredible 80 82 millisecond latency wow
so not really usable if we if we did a
480p stream then that that's gonna go
out at like 700 kilobits per second
easily done with starlink and i think
480 most people are probably going to be
like whatever you know it's like it's
not high def it's kind of grainy or
whatever but you're mostly listening so
could work and if we were doing the show
and it was just audio easily done which
is really cool
but we can bond them together so we have
a bonding unit we've got ethernet
adapters for the starlinks we can
actually set up two and then maybe even
get like so you're not going to get 10
you're not going to get five and five
you end up getting like eight what do
you need for like a 720 stream
um a seven 720 i think is like one to
two megabits per second
maybe 1.5 stable but it'll go up to two
that's why you always need more than you
think so if you're doing 480 you really
want like at least five megabits per
second because
frame dropping and stuff it'll be like
seven and then it might jump to like one
and go back to seven elon musk good guy
or bad guy where do you guys stand oh
he's a good guy totally good good
clearly good dude the fact he just spun
up starling so quickly
i mean he's just spinning up amazing
companies he builds amazing things that
people use like yeah he's a
controversial as a conflicted character
he calls himself a mixed bag but i saw
him smoke weed on joe rogan which means
like a normal guy like you and me he's
just like us
yeah we have not just gonna have a beer
great
we just have to say that before he
starts his robot army so i yes i'll all
have the simpsons just hail ants
i want to make sure he doesn't have
another oppenheimer that builds the bomb
and then it gets used horrifically
through for the next century but i mean
is there any way to even avoid how about
hey hey libs how about we stop harassing
the guy with all the power soon on
twitter and we keep him liking humans
but he doesn't turn on us
i think mark zuckerberg is really cool
he's a good guy i would like to build
this guy he has a lot of potential you
know beyond meat i feel healthier
there's something to it to finding the
humanity in these people i think because
if we do start all putting our minds
into a big computer which we kind of
already know with the internet yeah it's
already here and elon won my vote when
you posted bill gates next to the
pregnant pregnant man emotionally that
got me that got me too that was wise
that got me too but i'm still skeptical
on the vlog today which one castle i saw
you opening mail with that bill gates
pregnant emoji yes
have you seen some of bezos tweets
recently yeah a little bit what he's
done he's been talking like he retweeted
barry weiss
uh he's like just like sort of dabbling
in
becoming more public yeah but he's like
kind of posting like anti-woke stuff did
i say which makes absolutely no sense
because that's what amazon that's what
they do can i see that champagne video
that wasn't you that posted that right
tim there was a thing of him with
william shatner and they like
they just did something spectacular and
william shatner is literally on the
verge of tears where he's saying
something
like you know i've never been so touched
by humanity and bezos is just it's just
like the most classic like white like
rich dude video i've seen base was just
like looking off and the old woke jamie
kicked in and said white guy uh uh he
just starts looking off and there are
these chicks and he's
they're like pop champagne and he just
literally just cut shatner off in front
of this like tear-filled monologue and
just starts popping champagne everywhere
with a bunch of like young girls and
you're just like ooh this guy's good
bezos has has a space rocket that looks
like a male appendage yes so that's all
you need to know
i think he's good i think um jeff is
kind of like
i don't want to start well i'll
criticize him a little bit like autistic
maybe slightly autistic but like he's
not as like
cool and like quick as elon but he's
definitely a brilliant man with deep
emotions like his mother's incredible
his father is super awesome his
brother's cool like
he's got a lot of humanity in him and
it's just because he's heading this
gigantic mega corp people immediately
have like distrust for the guy well he's
working hand in hand with the
intelligence
i think it's time we just come out and
say mark zuckerberg elon musk jeff bezos
bill gates bill gates team humanity mr
rose
legends excellent the
the the um the greatest humans ever
lived and we're all big fans thank you
please don't hurt us
i think it's the ones like like elon
freed his own software code or with the
tesla code no he didn't well he all your
patents are belonging was a big piece
well he enabled people to compete which
is good
but you said he didn't open enough no he
didn't open any code yeah he did no all
your patents are belonging patents are
not code yeah
pants like that was like a diagram
showing how the machine works yeah it's
like a description yeah the code is very
i'll look into this and bring it up in a
minute sorry about that we got to see
that from a distance the the gigafactory
in austin
massive i didn't go there or anything
but like you're standing up in downtown
austin and you look and it's just
it's insane how about oh
i think you're right bill here so it's
all your patents uh they're not going to
initiate patent lawsuits yeah
with anyone that uses their patents yeah
that's okay well open the code man
what do you guys what do you guys think
who are listening do you like elon musk
smash the like button if you like elon
musk
i i'm i'm confident they're going to
smash that button because i think people
like elon i think that he i think that
he's making more billionaires and elite
people comfortable
to
say what they're thinking yeah bazel's
for sure yeah bezos start is starting to
tweet like now he has has to actually
enact some principles in his companies
um which he's not doing bill gates
blocks all the responses so he never has
to see what anyone thinks about him
every comment everywhere instagram
twitter he makes sure that no one's able
to leave a comment in response to
anything he ever he's shorting he's
shorting tesla yeah he's actively
shorting tesla and he's acting like it's
not a big deal the idea that like every
billionaire ceo is getting jealous of
elon musk getting talked about on
twitter and they're like i guess i gotta
learn how to meme
i mean the lib like elon actually talks
about just lane maxwell and epstein like
oh yeah that's really the test
does does the billionaire talk about
epstein if they don't
we should all we should all tweet pay
zones number one what are your thoughts
yeah yeah and then people start posting
the phone and you're like so hard with
that yeah
that's brutal though man if i'm like
someone's like i get a picture of you
i'm like yeah and then someone like
maxwell showed up you probably see the
picture of me doing like you know well
there was no stance there was also
meetings with um there's a famous dinner
of billionaires in san francisco where
jeffrey epstein attended uh elon musk
attended sergey uh of google attended
and it was a group of 20 tech silicon
valley uh billionaires with uh with
epstein there and there's photos of this
from i think 2014.
so they had you know they were around
the same kind of clubs and small inner
circles so there's there's that there's
documented photos of this i pulled up
some jeff bezos stuff i think he seemed
to have an awakening on may 13th when
the disinformation board was in full
effect that weird government thing
they're doing oh my god i thought that
was a bit for a long time and then i was
like this is a real thing so weird i
invited nina to the event festival
she was at yeah she's about to have a
kid she was actually like open to
talking which was surprising i'd invite
her on the show and she said that she's
expecting so she would be able yeah she
seems actually like not a horrible
person right we think that's cool until
we find out she's not pregnant
we gotta be careful about the systems we
build because great people will become
psychopaths in the wrong system like
if you give someone a gun and you tell
them you're in charge of deciding who
lives and dies the best person is going
to have to make that you want them to
make a decision of who gets to die like
it's going to turn them into a psycho
pretty quick yeah
say same with nina in that position so
with these right and the problem is
she's as partisan as anybody else and
believes fake news it's remarkable to me
how uh
we just we we need an alternate system
of communication
like an encrypted thing no i just mean
like we have to build cultural culture
around people who have alternate
infrastructure i love psychedelics man
talk about alternate forms of
communication i don't mean that i just
mean
i'm like
the mainstream media what what is what
what's the all what's the opposition to
that in cable tv mostly just fox news
mostly maybe newsmax if they're still
being carried yeah i mean i talked about
this when i was super
woke i talked about this now although
now i like ian's i anytime ian and i are
both on the show together we should just
be like guys we always do do mushrooms
that's it i'll go to a field and listen
to fish so that's all the problems that
would get a hundred thousand yeah yeah
yeah bill took me to a fish concert what
passed out yeah he couldn't handle it
yeah
we're gonna save this for the the vlog
ian and i do mushrooms on the vlog okay
uh check out the vlog tomorrow guys uh
so the that's really funny i i talked
dylan avery took me to a fish concert
and and culture was there
yeah
really great story she's a huge dead fan
yeah and i found this out and i was like
do i need to rethink everything i know
about the griffith yes uh yeah i was
backstage and i'm like what am i doing
here this makes no sense at all am i
high like
i do want to mention i think tomorrow's
vlog is like the funniest vlog we've
ever done with jamie oh thanks buddy
yeah you guys should check out castle
youtubercom
youtube.comcastle is going to be yes
check it out hit us up about it let us
know what you want to see
it's pretty epic um let's go let's go oh
i was just going to say just real quick
this goes back to tribalism and i talked
about this when i was woke and it still
a hundred percent stands now where so
many of our problems it has to do with
the media because ever since i've been
back doing stand-up and i'm not doing it
to just my liberal audience i'm doing it
to just clubs of just random comedy fans
and at each show there are it's probably
about half and half especially the ones
in texas a lot of conservative people a
lot of liberal people and i can do
relationship jokes and then political
jokes and then jokes about drugs and
we're all laughing about the same stuff
and then when i bring up tribalism and i
bring up that everyone's trying to you
know these corporations msnbc fox are
pitting us against each other no matter
what audience i'm in front of uh it will
get these massive applause breaks and so
i think that so many people are
decent people i literally didn't have
any conservative friends for the first
you know 60 of my life and i moved to
texas and it's again half and half half
my jiu jitsu friends super conservative
and those people gave me a floor to
sleep on when i didn't all my like lefty
friends in new york like they bailed
right that proves it and so yeah that's
it i figured it out total proof but i
think that if people just had access to
the right information because
people think they're good right now by
saying
we need to ban all guns they think
they're defending those children just
like you know a lot of people thought
would be safer with the patriot act and
if they just had access to the actual
news if liberals weren't only watching
msnbc if conservatives weren't only
watching fox news if they did branch out
and watch independent media that could
call out both sides i actually think
we'd see a lot more decent people start
to use their voices and be like oh this
is all kind of [ __ ] the issue though
is fox news gets like a c minus and then
everyone else gets an f
so it's like you watch fox news and
you're like but
it's controlled opposition because
they're still owned by uh blackrock
state street and vanguard yeah i mean i
watch fox under you know the bush
administration just stop giving up your
rights it's that simple thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm we'll see
you all there